the google cloud sdk what is it
the google cloud software development
kit is a collection of tools that are
used to interact with google cloud apis
and services and manage the resources in
your google cloud projects
together these tools help developers and
technical practitioners be more
efficient when interacting with google
cloud
the sdk includes the google cloud cli
cloud client libraries
developer tools and documentation
the first piece of the google cloud sdk
is the google cloud cli a collection of
command line tools you can install to
access and manage your cloud from the
command line
with it you can do all kinds of things
like manage virtual machines query
bigquery tables
update cool cloud storage buckets and
virtually anything else you can do in
the cloud console all from your linux
mac os or windows terminal
next in our sdk are cloud client
libraries for programmatically
integrating google cloud apis into your
code
with high level api abstractions cloud
client libraries handle all the
low-level details of communicating with
google cloud
this greatly reduces the boilerplate
code you would have to write otherwise
and lowers a learning curve so you can
hit the ground running and start coding
effectively and more quickly most
importantly cloud client libraries are
available for several programming
languages including java python node.js
go ruby c-sharp and php each sdk will
also have language specific frameworks
and tools as available so you'll have
everything you need no matter what your
favorite language is
cloud client libraries are available for
more than 100 google cloud services to
help you better understand how to best
use them the google cloud sdk also
includes detailed documentation that
we've centralized on cloud.google.com
so you'll always have access to
consistent authoritative and update
technical reference documentation and
code snippets
and finally the sdk optionally includes
cloud code an ide extension available
for vs code and intellij that helps you
write debug and deploy cloud native apps
all without ever needing a switch from
your ide window
do you want to get started using the
google cloud sdk
the google cloud cli is available via
your operating system's package manager
or a direct download from
cloud.google.com and cloud client
libraries can be installed via standard
library package managers like npm and
pip or via the language-specific google
cloud client library's repositories
linked in the description of this video
to learn more about the google cloud sdk
check out cloud.google.com
sdk
[Music]
you